Prince Harry joins a Coldplay  okay he's not joining the band but he  did it join them onstage at Tuesday  nights at Sentebale concert at  Kensington Palace Sentebale means  forget-me-nots in Sesotho an African  language the event raised money and  awareness for young people affected by  hiv/aids in Africa the prince co-founded  the Sentebale organization in 2006 harry  joined a cult play and a youth choir to  close out the concert with a performance  of the band song up and up before that  harry gave a speech Tuesday urging the  crowd to get more involved with the  fight against hiv/aids quote what we  know is that HIV is a virus that thrives  off silence and feeds on stigma every  single one of us has a responsibility to  educate ourselves